Guys, c'mere…
I have a secret…
the military has a secret space shuttle!
oh, everyone already knew that.
So in case you didn't already know, the U.S.
Air Force has a SECRET SPACE SHUTTLE!
If you pay attention to space news, you probably
already heard about it.
I mean, Vandenberg Air Force Base sent out
a press release last week telling the world
it was landing last Tuesday!
It's called the X-37B, and the secret part
isn't that it exists, but what it's FOR.
Here's what we DO know: The reusable orbiter
is a fourth the size of the old NASA space
shuttle -- which means it's only 9 and-a-half
feet tall (2.9M) and not quite 30 feet long
(8.9M).
It's unmanned, and fully automated.
It's launched atop an Atlas V rocket and can
stay in space for a LONG time, using solar
panels to power itself, and when one landed
in 2010 it did so autonomously.
NASA started the X37 project in 1999 and transferred
it to the Defence Advanced Research Projects
Agency -better known as DARPA - in 2004.
Her first flight was in 2006, and there have
since been three orbital flights and two tiny
orbiters built…
The third mission ended this week, more than
doubling the time in space of the previous
mission.
The Air Force is open with all this information,
but when asked what the X-37B is DOING up
there… that's when things get all Area 51-ish.
They're quote "testing technologies," "operating
experiments," and trying to create a quote
"fast-turnaround vehicle -- making sure it
can be re-fueled and re-launched within days"
rather than months.
But the theories as to what it's doing up
there abound!
According to amateur astronomers it flies
around 218 miles up (350km), above the ISS,
and an ideal altitude for spying -- says some
sources.
Popular Mechanics did a short round-up, and
they say the three major theories are these:
it's either a spy plane -- spying from space
is ideal, the media has worried about it,
and those astronomers say the orbit should
fly over Afghanistan, Iran and Pakistan.
Hmm… perhaps it's a space-based bomber!
The payload bay is small, but no so much that
the X-37B couldn't hold a nuke!
(Of course, NASA studied this in the 60s,
and found nuclear blasts in space, or high
orbit can mess with a LARGE section of Earth.
Why risk taking a nuke to space?!
It could screw up communications globally,
and irradiate a lot of the surface.
Based on actual nuclear tests in space, NASA
discovered radiation exposure between 8 and
17 times higher than at sea level with the
same explosive.
That's horrifying.
Plus the amount of fuel required to move a
spacecraft around in space makes a space-bomber
of that size fairly useless.
) THIS SEEMS TO TAKE THE SCRIPT A BIT OFF
THE RAILS - COULD CUT.
Maybe…
*GASP* the government is telling the truth,
and it's for experiments!
The Air Force is known for trying cutting
edge tech, so maybe?
I dunno.
Regardless, the X-37B's third mission came
to an end this week, bringing all this to
the surface again.
Neither Boeing nor the Air Force are saying
anything about the exact mission, but Boeing
is already contracted to create the X-37C,
which is 65-percent larger -- meaning it could
carry up to six astronauts.
What do you think these secret shuttles are
for?
Are they going to fly to the far side of the
moon and look for aliens?
WHAT DOES IT DOOOOO??